so you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
perfect yo
what's up guys welcome back to the dope
as usual podcast i am thomas dobaziola
i'm here with marty o'neal what's up
what the
oh try not to cuss i'm trying to be a
nice kid today uh it's not gonna happen
guys welcome back to the dopes usual
podcast we are here to talk about life
blank
problems accomplishments and everything
in between i'm trying something we
rosie's uh episode got age restricted
and we talked about her being in church
so i don't know what youtube's on right
now so i'm trying not to say
the f word
for a while all right your [ __ ]
seriously it's not gonna happen that's
not gonna happen how are you gonna age
restrict the goddamn rosie video granted
yes we were talking about things in the
first half of the [ __ ] episode yeah
but the second name was so wholesome
like it was come on
we gotta get some bonus [ __ ]
wholesome points off that one
so uh i'm trying my best to not be so
damn vulgar
right off the bat
because i would like youtube to you know
recommend our channel anyway you guys
have heard that many times so i'm not
gonna keep dwelling on it
today from the title from the title
you're ready
this is police encounters i'm getting
right into it i'm treating this like a
story time episode marty okay i need one
thing from you today besides all the 90
other things you have to do while doing
this episode
i need you to tell me when we're getting
close to 15 minutes i don't want any
story i do go over 15 because i want to
stay precise
i want to get right into it now goes one
time in the third grade i got punched
like i don't want to do any of that [ __ ]
i'm trying to stay on point you guys
this is the episode just keep smoking
keep rolling keep packing do whatever
you're doing keep hanging out chilling
drinking with your friends
this is the episode to pay attention to
no topics i mean no uh current topics no
events no news no nothing i want to go
all stories on this one
100
okay
all right let's do it i talk about
nothing else i'm getting straight into
it you let me know when it's 10 minutes
because i'm gonna light that
back yeah
youtube all right we don't know what to
do i don't even know yeah i don't know
yeah we just want to stop we can't be
having the podcast get age restricted on
top of every yola video
man go get the app is the point
yes double zola app on the app store and
now google play store okay the dopagiol
app is live we'll talk about it much
more later but let's for now let's get
into these stories
all right guys so yesterday i went over
every single episode of this podcast
we've ever done scrubbed through it and
made sure i wrote down every single
story that i could find
that way i'm not going marty have i told
this before so guys i'm trying to be
super professional be on my [ __ ] so
these stories i went through all the
podcast episodes i didn't see me talk
about any of these
if i did talk about them i'm very very
very very sorry that i'm talking about
it again
but it'll always be fun okay so this is
what i'm gonna show you as i'm gonna
tell you we'll never repeat anything i
have
you saw my notes extensive notes for
every episode every podcast and every
story time i wrote them all down
cross-referenced them to make sure we're
good
let's get started guys and i'm going
chronologically
okay i'm gonna go chronologically this
is gonna start
when i was 15 years old are you ready
this is story time
i don't know what filter or overlay
you're going to use
what buttons are pressing oh okay
okay that took a minute
it's the official that's the official
one
right it's story time
i like that all right you guys ready
here we go this is going to be called
police encounters please tell me when it
no what time are we at
four minutes
yeah about there i got to do a little
math because i had to hustle around
looking for a [ __ ] lighter for a
minute okay so we're at three minutes
okay
um so like i said this is the episode
i'm trying to stay completely on point
i'm not even high
i'm chilling
i want to i'm going to see if i can do
it for myself i want to see if i can do
this so we're at five minutes yeah
please don't let me go over 15. okay but
please tell me we're getting close but
also tell me when i can light this joint
all right i've been trying
thank you oh of all episodes exactly
this is police encounters guys and these
are stories that i have not hold on on
the podcast at all yet
and every single story you're about to
hear is from the dopaziola channel
season one of story time
first story takes place when i am 15
years old
let me tell you exactly what happened
my mom's a dick you guys know that and
my dad is moving away
i stay the night with my dad and i tell
him dad
um can you please sign me out of school
you know i was like ah
i don't feel great oh you can sign me
out of school and he just signed me out
of school this is what happened
i told him i was going to school
i lied to my mom and asked oh no i told
him i was going to stay and
dude it's so confusing i'm sorry i'm
sorry let me start it again let me start
it again
my mom says hey you cannot stay at your
dad you never do i go but he's moving
away tomorrow please
mom that's what happened so i she said
okay you can stay at your dad's i lied
to my dad he signed me he called the
school and said thomas is sick he's not
coming to school today
and i lied to my dad i just went to my
friends i told him i was gonna do
something
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway my mom thinks i'm with my dad my
dad signed me out of school doesn't know
where i'm at
i'm just gone
you know what i'm saying i know i can't
remember the lie i told him but
i just left so i'm going around town
with my friends like hood rat hoodlums
and i uh
end up with this guy named shawn's
shawn's and this kid brandon their best
homies they're one year younger than me
but shawn's mom
is like 25 26 years old
i thought it was a sister it's his mom
she lets us get high in his house first
time i ever watched how high
was in that room nice she lets us get
high at his house she orders food and
[ __ ]
cool mom
but bad parent
yeah
all right fine line yes i've never met
his dad i know his dad's older but his
mom's mad young so it's one of those
relationships you know but his dad's
right to have a really nice house i
don't know what his dad did i never
talked to the guy they had a trampoline
we smoked joints and jumped on
trampoline
so this is what happened guys we smoked
a bunch of bowls on the side of shawn's
house because his mom's not home she
didn't have a key so we're like [ __ ] we
get all over here we're all hitting the
bong as kid johnny throws up from the
bong rip it's first time i ever saw
anybody throw up from weed
he threw up from the bomber from
coughing and coughing
there's about 12 of us
we all did school and we all just
collectively met up right
met up at sean's like yo let's walk to
ryan's
so you guys real quick if you're in the
car just pay attention uh if you're on
youtube check us out here's my school on
the left side across the creek
a neighborhood then shawn's house
right main road
main road my mom's death
getting caught by his ditching right
here is death
okay but next door to death is taco bell
so we're pushing it all right i was
always doing like the
flip your collar up like [ __ ] my mom's
gonna see me oh [ __ ] scurry along the
wall like a like a soldier and [ __ ]
i did everything okay
so
we smoke a bun i am [ __ ] high i just
remember thinking whoa i'm high as [ __ ]
i should be in second period you know
that feeling when you're supposed to be
in class you look at the time go
i'd be in history right now [ __ ] yeah
it's the best the best thank you that's
why i like you it's the best feeling
[ __ ] ever i'm like oh my god it means
math stop giving kids math in the
morning nobody [ __ ] wants math class
in the morning stop being a [ __ ]
so
we all leave sean's house in a group
collectively in a group
sean's is right next door to this big
dentist office off of g and el patel you
know exactly if you're from merced right
next to a hot sanded uh hot santa too
that street up for el patel and uh g
street so this is what happens me and
brandon were just talking this kid
brandon
all eight to ten other the kids are
right next to us me and brandon go
around the building this way i don't
know why we were just talking
nothing sim nothing crazy
we were just talking and everyone else
decided to go around the building to the
right side nothing serious when you you
know what i mean when you when you cross
over you're going to meet up you're not
losing your friends
so
oh ho ho
ho thank you
this is what got me in trouble so i was
really high right
um
[Music]
so we crossed the building and as we get
around the building me and brandon just
talk we're just talking and we look over
i'm like where's everybody at they're
not like
slower than i am it's just
not a huge you know what i mean guys the
doctor's office you walk around the
sidewalk gonna meet up on the other side
there's nothing
nothing serious when i get on the other
side of the building i look for them
like where the [ __ ] are they we're just
walking
and i look around the bushes
and the [ __ ] campus police has them
all sitting against the curb
in 20 seconds of us going the wrong way
campus police pulls up officer lucas
[ __ ] you
pulls up on us
pulls up on them has them all sitting
and his back is toward us
but all our friends can see us
like oh they went the other
get out of here like you could see them
all like
get the [ __ ] out of here
but they're all sitting there like [ __ ]
we're high
no we're in the 10th grade like [ __ ] no
we're all high
and the officer lucas has his back
toward us remember because he just
thinks it's all them so he doesn't turn
around like is there any more yeah so we
see them and go oh no
and me and brandon
tightrope walk on this
you know the bush is right here covering
so i had to look over and then i saw him
all lined up like no so what we did was
i try to stay behind the eye of the
blood like the line of the bush
and like tip toe tight rope walk our
asses
sprintish
down albertel to g to cross over because
we had if you from the town there's
nowhere to go it's the main street
it's the main road you have to go to a
house or a business and none of us
shawn's house is now off limits right
he's getting arrested by the campus
police
so me and brandon as soon as we hit g
street which is like a block away we
just sprint we don't even look back we
don't even know if he's looking at us we
just sprint we start i had a blue
backpack on
fat kid just spraying down the street
spreading down the street as fast as we
can
hook a left when i hook a left guys when
i hook a left i see all the
hey bill like all the old white men
wanting their lawn
oh the kids one of those guys like that
that neighborhood but they're all like
in their 70s so they don't got [ __ ] to
do they're sitting there watering their
lawn
normal citizens
and as soon as i crossed them running
with brandon i go oh man they're gonna
they're gonna call the cops they're
gonna call the cops [ __ ]
so
we take another left as as we take a
left i see all these old men i take
another left and as i do i look up and
go oh court
[ __ ]
so i just keep running down the court
and go so where are we going to go
you say like what the [ __ ] and i hear
they're over there go [ __ ] snitch
you old [ __ ] oh white man [ __ ] you
brandon's a six two pretty white kid
so it wasn't a racial thing that he
snitched on us he just knew we were
delinquents
you know
so before i hear they're over there
me and brandon just say hi behind this
huge bush we're in someone's front
[ __ ] yard
10 30 in the morning
so early for them so early for this
delinquent [ __ ]
we're sitting in the front yard i'm
hiding behind a bush you ever heard this
right no okay i'm hiding behind a bush
and i'm a fat kid i could squat all the
way down but i'm doing the whole hands
on the knees thing i don't want to squat
for five minutes
i didn't realize my backpack's just
sticking out
you know what i'm saying like a shell
yes like a [ __ ] teenage mutant ninja
turtle shell just
delinquent shell
and
i see your backpack man
oh
and brandon looks at me like
you fat kid i could just get on the
ground
i look again like [ __ ] i'm so sorry
so you both stand up like oh [ __ ] man
so they told me where you were you
[ __ ] stitch ass old men
puts us in the back of the car none of
our other friends are with them he made
them walk back to school on the honor
system
they all walked to the principal's
office
i would have not
they actually went but he took all their
student ids
so he knew they were who they were you
know and isn't it weird guys is
i'm 20. i'll [ __ ] run anywhere i'm
not getting caught [ __ ] you i'll run and
jump to two fences as a 16 year old like
he has my name oh my god my life's over
i wish i wasn't such a [ __ ] when i was
younger thinking about getting in
trouble like what you gonna do punch me
no your mom wasn't my mom
yeah yeah but as soon as she punched me
in the you know what that's what it was
when she when i realized she ain't [ __ ]
and she had no power behind that punch i
went oh i'm gonna do whatever i want
sorry back to the story
we get in the back of the of the
cop car and i'm like dude i've never
been in the back of a cob car [ __ ] and
it's officer lucas you're a [ __ ] anyway
he's not a real cop but he is
you know i mean campus police
i'm getting escorted
almost third period getting escorted by
officer lucas like this
hand on my back and [ __ ] brandon was
like no man
[ __ ]
remember the school's not far
i see your backpack i just felt stupid
in the back car walk in the principal's
office all of my friends are sitting
down
oh [ __ ]
no
i'm high as [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] high i just quit football
the week before
i'm fresh out of being a good kid to go
like
now you're ditching and getting caught
by campus but like [ __ ]
so what happens guys
he calls all my friends in one at a time
i don't know what for
three kids behind me three of my friends
behind me and then
i'm like the fourth to last being called
so he calls up like eight people
i go in and he goes all right sit down
starts giving me the drug test the eye
test which does [ __ ] nothing
all she's trying to all if anybody ever
does the eye test you for weed they're
just trying to see if you look scared
there is no test i'm gonna nail that
[ __ ] test if i'm high i nailed it i
did the whole thing you went
you're really good at this because now
you're high
that's what he said like you're really
good at this i know you're high really
bad at testing for hardness no he just
did this
and it was all thomas just follow his
finger yeah but he does this one
and when he does this it's supposed to
make your eyes flicker when you're
[ __ ] up but it doesn't that's like a
1950s trick
what the [ __ ] he was like you're really
good at this because i know you're high
go ahead man that's why you passed i
went i'm not high officer lucas he goes
just go man i walked out i looked my
friend
yes like
i try not to let him behind me see it
and then my friend nate gomez failed
right after failed attested had to call
his mom say he was on drugs
but um
so what happened what happened i'm still
i'm i still got caught ditching
under suspicion of smoking weed right
i'm sitting there but what hold on what
do i have all you attentive listeners
get out of jail free card because my dad
called and said i wasn't going to school
um
he's like so i'm gonna call your parents
and i'd raise my hand and go
i'm allowed to not be in school and he
loses it
he did not like me saying that he
[ __ ] cussed at me got in my face no
one has a [ __ ] right to not be in
[ __ ] school you do not have a [ __ ]
pass to be out of school and me pick you
up
and i go
but i do i'm an [ __ ] and especially
if i'm right i'll [ __ ] [ __ ] on you i
go but but under this circumstances i do
officer lucas okay no one does that no
one has the right go call my [ __ ] dad
yo
this man gets on the phone on the phone
with my dad he's heated
oh
so you did
we have to get him anyway hangs up on my
dad
i wasn't in trouble he looked at me and
just like
he was so [ __ ] mad that i had to get
out of jail free card because my dad's
like yeah i signed him out he's not even
supposed to be in school so you picked
him up for nothing
and he was heeded
but the worst part about this whole
story
is my dad had to actually come get me
and he looks so disappointed in me
my crank addict dad looks so
disappointed in me
come on thomas
what he did in school
jesus christ this is before
guys we're getting dr drew on by the way
we're going to go over all this oh yeah
dr drew's about to be a guest for
everyone out there
he's going to i can't wait till he hears
all this [ __ ]
what time we are
if we're at like 18 we're going 19. oh
my god we [ __ ] did it in 15 minutes
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the end of
the story nice
all right all right chapter one
you guys ready for more
i actually hired a bunch of people
they're just out there studio audiences
yeah we hired our studio audience
they're on the roof
i didn't hire them
i didn't hire them
you ready
are you ready what are the oh okay i saw
you about to press more buttons
okay here we go here we go
like i said
i'm on it today is a story time day it's
my favorite kind of [ __ ]
okay
this next
story story number two story time
overlay
[Music]
okay here we go
this next story takes place
same exact year
about a couple weeks later maybe even if
a couple weeks later
i had quit football and you guys know my
best friend in high school was joe fish
joe fish
also quit football same year i did joe
sucked at football he was second string
quarterback
you know like he's just
and he's white
if you ever heard shane gillis there are
no white cornerbacks
and he's not lying
joe is not a good very bad football
player but he was a really good
basketball player
anyway i remember the day this happened
i'm hanging out and joe was like the
popular more popular kid because he's
very pretty all the girls like joe
everyone knows me i'm not a popular kid
like i don't like the music you like
you guys are gonna watch step it up okay
i'm not going i was that kid i'm the
[ __ ] kid that doesn't like any of
this [ __ ] that all the popular kids like
because i don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
i'm not a glee kid
okay
hanging out the quad i'd rather not
i'll i'll go over there once a week i'll
come to the quad if you want some weed
but uh i was that kid
joe was the opposite he was very
popular kid
he asked me to hang out he's like yo
what's up man go to my house my mom's
coming my mom's leaving you don't play
football anymore i don't play smoke weed
he goes you smile
yeah
[ __ ] yeah i smoke weed
i've never been drunk before guys
joe goes i'm gonna have some people over
on friday night my mom's gone you should
come over first like
party high school party party that
someone's like no you come with me ninth
grade we just went to parties as
freshmen and got [ __ ] up
this time joe's like come with me
joe's a cool cool dude but he's like i
said every girl just [ __ ] likes joe
so everyone knows who joe is so i'm like
all right
i'll hang out with this kid
and he turned out to be one of my best
[ __ ] friends ever
go to joe's house
here's your
here we go
i started drinking this bottle he had it
was called parrot's bay you ever heard
of parrot's bay
terrible alcohol i was drinking parrots
bae
i've never been drunk i'm drinking it
out the bottle
drinking out of the [ __ ] bottle it
was a coconut or pineapple tropical one
of the things i've ever had fruit on it
i'm drinking this liquor i'm like
i have long hair at this time i'll send
you the picture yeah
put it in
um so this is what happened guys we're
there it's just me joe anthony like his
friend elizal
before i really knew eliza and like four
other people so we're just hanging out
about six o'clock
about eight o'clock
there's like 20 more people because joe
invites one girl and this girl invites a
girl and that girl invites a girl and
then she finds four dudes and that four
dudes
i'm sitting on joe's counter with my leg
on the counter like we're chilling and
i'm drinking parrots bae
right and then the song mr brightside by
the killers came on
and i remember to listen to the song oh
that sounds tight and i'm looking around
and all these older like all the senior
kids i could i know they're the senior
kids they're [ __ ] got beards
all of them were just sitting there like
someone looking at me i'm just sitting
there drinking a [ __ ] bottle like
long-haired kid just on the counter like
you guys want some weed yeah you guys
want to buy weed um
oh no no i hadn't started selling weed
yet a couple weeks after that is when me
and joe's weed career started but at
that time i had weed i was smoking weed
all the time and um
so this is what happened
sitting there drinking the killers comes
on like i'm at a high school park you
know you ever heard that feeling you
ever remember that feeling like whoa i'm
in high school now
whoa these fools are doing drug drugs oh
[ __ ] there's girls getting oh [ __ ]
it's what part my first party ever went
to so we're all chilling everything's
going great and this girl jessica comes
over and she's a super popular chick and
joe likes her a lot
and i'm like ah
well i'll watch your house joe
i got your house go do whatever you're
gonna do and he goes to his room with
his chick
and it's like 30 minutes later and i'm
the guy open the door what's up over
here for the party all right come in
little dude how are you coming and all
the baby's like what's your name
ah you can come in man i was just like
i'll take responsibility for your house
[ __ ] these guys because they're all
older like
these little kids it's that it's our
house [ __ ]
yeah it's our liquor too [ __ ] you and um
the whole entire backyard's full of
people i mean there's about 70 [ __ ]
people plus
at joe's first birthday i mean joe's
first party
all these people were showing up in
groups and joe was in his room there's
about double the amount of people since
joe went to his room so he's gonna come
and go what the [ __ ]
shoulder to shoulder in his house it was
bad
and then i hear cops
i look out the front door and there's
[ __ ] squad cars
all right look at the front window i'm
like oh my [ __ ] god
run to joe's room i knock go away it's
thomas
go go away i'm like joe there's [ __ ]
cops outside i hear
two seconds later open the door
you seriously go there's a lot of cops
outside you should go talk to them at
the door
because they're gonna knock
i go out and i just go
cops are here and i hear other people
cops and everyone just starts rushing
like ants going through a tunnel
from the house to the backyard and i
just do this
no
let me not be an [ __ ] i went oh
and then i just briskly walked
sprinted
to joe's mom's room
because i know they're not gonna search
joe's mom's room they're gonna look on
the bed
like there's nobody following me it's a
zombie apocalypse and i found a hiding
space let's just say that
while there's zombies eating people
outside
i found a space so this is what i go
that's what i do i open joe's mom's room
turn the light back off so nobody knows
i'm in there and i go to the window of
her bathroom i look
and there's so many people i recognize
from school
all squished together on the side of the
house trying to figure out how to open
the [ __ ] side gate
everybody is tunneling from the inside
to the outside
i look and i see this kid mark which is
going to be in the next [ __ ] the next
same mark is in the next story i have
this kid
i look at him and i like close the
blinds i'm like i don't want nobody to
see me in here and try to take my hiding
spot [ __ ] you guys and i just peek again
and i just see this
and joe's entire fence
entire side fence just gets taken down
bam
whole thing
because all these people were oh my god
oh my [ __ ] god but i remember looking
like
what the were they trying to climb there
there were so many people trying to get
over the fence at the same time that the
whole thing went
this is not the first time it's fenced
people just i'll get into that so i see
the fence going to go oh [ __ ] joe's in
trouble
i go into joe's mom's closet because
guys at this point i'm like all right
i am not getting caught drunk and [ __ ]
up and they're gonna call my mom not
gonna happen
remember this is like 11 o'clock at
night
joe's mid about to bang the girl that he
likes and i ruined it first off so i'm
in the closet i sit down and like
okay
guys i i am
i think fast
if there's a murderer
i'm probably gonna hide i mean i'm
probably gonna not get killed if he's
like doing the whole jason thing i'm
probably gonna be like yo yeah that's a
great hiding spot thomas damn i'm gonna
be under this table like matilda
like just flattened out you'll never
find me
i look in joe's mom's claws i'm looking
around with my phone light from my koi
motorola koi phone i'm just shining the
line i go
okay yeah i started pulling all joe's
mom's clothes from the hangers on top of
my body
like as many as i could all of them all
of them and then i grabbed all the
clothes on the floor and started piling
on my legs i put myself my back against
the wall in the corner and i started
piling all the clothes i dropped some
hangers everywhere and i just did this i
laid under all the clothes on a pile
like where they touched the walls i was
like damn this [ __ ] don't do her
laundry
and then i just held the bottom so i can
look underneath
in case i needed to look underneath the
pile my head's on the ground and i just
go fall sleep full put your phone on
silent i'm done
i'm not moving
three
four minutes later i hear the door open
and two people having a conversation
regular conversation
i'm like these are cops
nobody at this party's gonna have a
conversation with the cops in here
and i hear these [ __ ] kids like all
right you see them all jump the fence
like yeah man they're just talking the
cops are now in joe's mom's room
looking for somebody just just making
sure there's nobody else in there
they're not i don't know what they're
touching
but i hear him just conversating well
and i'm like oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god
and i hear the jurassic park
on the linoleum floor in the bathroom
and i'm just in the closet and i dropped
it so i closed my eyes i just
try to hold
[Laughter]
what's wrong with you
oh that was good
that was scary though
i don't know if you should do that one
that was a little
much
[ __ ] handsome oh that's great that's
been on the soundboard for a minute
waiting for the right moment well okay
then that's right and now i'm happy
because that was a perfect moment yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] opens the closet
door i go
because i don't want to breathe because
then you're gonna see the clothes move
i used to be i'm a great hiding sig
player as a kid i'll [ __ ] [ __ ] your
[ __ ] up
so i'm sitting there like yo these
clothes these clothes are going to save
me
remember i'm in joe's mom's closet
just ruined her whole wardrobe
thinking about that when you're saying
that i [ __ ] her whole [ __ ] up she
knows what she she knows what she left
i [ __ ] her whole [ __ ] up i'm under
there i hear the closet door
hold my breath he's just talking to the
guy he's talking closes the door and
walks out the [ __ ] room
emma yell so he looked at you
he looked at me but i was under all the
clothes yeah and i hold my breath so it
wouldn't
like move
and i'm thinking i'm a [ __ ] baller
and i still hear [ __ ]
i text joe like three times he never
[ __ ] answers my damn joe is arrested
i'm in his house alone
okay
all right joe's mom's in santa cruz
there's no way she's getting back guys i
had my phone right i had my phone i was
in there for over two hours just sitting
there waiting
uh i don't hear anybody else but i'm not
taking the chance of coming out
i'm waiting i'll give it the three hour
mark and i'll come out
i hear nobody i hear nothing no more
people no more partying no more music no
cops no talking
and i just had my phone line and was
like looking around the closet i am
[ __ ] just sitting there bored
i find this plastic bag i open the
plastic bag and joe's mom
smokes [ __ ] weed
after all the [ __ ] she gives him and
gives us for getting high
she gets high
so here we go it's the night i found out
joe's mom grows weed has a weed farm and
smokes
i found a straight cow patty the
nastiest weed i've ever at first i went
what it
this is weed i didn't know it was weed
at first that's how bad the weed was
that flat brown
puck
that
brick mexican brick she [ __ ] got a
mexican brick weed and went ah take that
corner
it was
disgusting but i remember looking at
like no
[ __ ] way you smoke weed
so
stories what time we at
about 30. i've only been talking for
five minutes on this story nah you
wrapped up that oh it's been 10 minutes
we're doing good yeah yeah
here we go
so
um it's about an hour
almost three and i'm like yeah i'm just
gonna come out
i open the door
i open joe's mom's door
and i'm like oh my god i hear nobody
i walk out the hall i remember the
hallway and everything i walk out the
hallway
and i do this one kitchen to the left i
look at the kitchen
i look to the right and go
joe
just to say it
and i didn't see joe joe was laying on
the couch pops up
had no idea i was still in his house
screen at the top of his macaulay coke
and
pops up
what the [ __ ] i go bro oh my god where
were you i thought you got arrested blah
blah blah like dude i've been in your
mom's closet for three [ __ ] hours
like you know you haven't go go look at
her closet i hit all and i explained i
walked him there
walked him into the closet go look
look i took it all down bro i was under
that that [ __ ] i explained a bit
i saw mark i saw mark at the fence your
fence beside my fence it's broken your
fence is broken he'd even know there's
one in the morning he had no [ __ ]
idea so
i'm explaining all this to him and i go
and i also found your mom's weed he goes
what the [ __ ] did you say he knew she
smoked sweet he didn't know she left
weed we smoked almost all that weed that
night you guys are savages we had to
we're like oh you're already in trouble
smoke all the [ __ ] weed bro i want to
get high you i'm not even drunk anymore
i'm just sitting here parrot's bae don't
do [ __ ] and i'm sitting here like yo
let's smoke we smoked almost
she had a half zip we smoked
10 grams
we left her with an eighth
it was over we smoked it all until the
morning came and then i walked home
that was the first time i ever hung out
with joe did you try to fix her closet i
don't even remember we probably did i
wouldn't left it like that i don't i
don't that i don't remember
she's got the [ __ ] up fence she's got
the cops knowing that there's a giant
yeah her [ __ ] weed is gone
and all her wardrobe
oh man
there was a time it got bad to where he
wasn't allowed to have nobody over
because he can't get in trouble so every
time we do his mom pulled up we just
walk out the back and she opens the door
to walk out the side and leave
yeah that was i did that a million times
a million times and then there was a
ditch right now it's the neighborhood
behind la siena two but that used to be
a field there used to be a little like
empty ditch and me and joe would go and
hide in there because i always told him
no fool we're gonna get people calling
the cops and see a spark
in the field and know people are getting
high my my ultimate goal is to never get
caught with my mom
never get caught because my mom will
find out
so me and joe would get under the level
hide in a ditch we'd smoke joints and
we'd smoke [ __ ] blunts and hit the
pipe we took his mom's pipe many times
and um
that's what me and joe used to do all
the [ __ ] time but
yeah i remember just wow serial killer
would have not saw my ass
pile of clothes and then i got away with
it that's it that's sick it was awesome
that's a badass story it was awesome bro
i was
i was excited and i actually i don't
talk to joe anymore obviously because
all the [ __ ] but i talked to his mom
he's talking to mom the other day
actually
she's [ __ ] cool she know all this
[ __ ]
they're doing so bad that i don't think
she gives a [ __ ] about the weed party
but i mean like does she
would she find it funny now like
probably oh she has like a she would
have listened to that [ __ ] now dude yeah
she doesn't know what i do
yeah she has no idea about all this [ __ ]
but
i'm sure she would find it funny she's
cool as [ __ ] i would give her a weed and
[ __ ] when i'm going back to the merced
she's awesome she's super cool we got we
became really good friends with joe
started getting kind of [ __ ] up
because we should like can you come help
me i'm like yeah
what park
you know like it's not fun
but uh
yeah that's that story bro
what time are we at fully
37 we'll call it oh that's not bad
that's not bad
a little break marty
you got a police story you can tell us
i asked marty i told him about the
police stories that's what we're gonna
do today
and he goes i have a couple and he
busted out a list of 45 no i just
literally i might drive up here when you
said that i'm like yeah i'm sure i got a
couple
i'm like i've already talked about like
four or five police stories on the
podcast
but then i'm like i was just doing like
some text to talk on my notepad on the
way up here and by the time i got here
the [ __ ]
thing was full
yeah
give us your best one marty looking back
on it they used to just [ __ ] with this
all the time like this [ __ ] was like the
wire like guacajuana if you look at it
it looks like the [ __ ] wire we'd be
sitting my boys would be getting raided
all the time we'd be sitting all the
time they'd [ __ ] with us we'd think that
they were about to raid all that type of
[ __ ] she did tell me about
something about the two kids that pulled
out aks out of their pants
that was there was really no cops
involved in that that was i mean there
was
but that that was [ __ ] horrible that
was
like like it was nothing well i mean
yeah i wasn't even going to bring that
one up but
i'll be super [ __ ] general with this
one this is extremely vague
this isn't even a cop story really i
mean until the [ __ ] end but i had one
boy that like he would be over at his
babies mamas different babies mamas and
there was one stint at one of his girls
houses where i would go over and kind of
end up meeting the dudes in these
neighborhoods wherever he was [ __ ]
stationed at yeah and these were some
young [ __ ] wild boys over where he
was at wild as [ __ ] and one time they
just they came over and we're all just
sitting there chilling they all pull
[ __ ] rifles out of their jackets out
of their jackets out of the sleeves of
their jackets
probably four or five of them
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and they're
just like they're on some yeah we're
about to go see these [ __ ] over
here all this time i was like what the
[ __ ] happened he's like ah they're
talking some gully [ __ ] that's all it
was
so literally we're sitting there
chilling we come over they all pull out
they all these kids are probably [ __ ]
15 16. oh god
ugh we had been chilling i had been
chilling with these kids like uh nothing
to lose frequently while i had you know
my boy had been stationed over there
and
so
they leave they go off on foot me and my
other boy go to get some [ __ ] dutches
and [ __ ] kind of behind him like maybe
just a few minutes later they walked out
and then we're like alright yeah we're
gonna go get some judges or [ __ ] like
damn that was crazy it was crazy to me
and my boy that i was with my boy who i
thought they just pulled out rifles yeah
my other boy that was completely [ __ ]
normal to him like he thought and he
wouldn't have thought twice about that
[ __ ] yeah so we go up do we get to the
gas station by the time we get to the
gas station 10 squad cars come flying
down the [ __ ] street
past us
yeah
and then these boys are back outside in
front of the [ __ ] house
they did some [ __ ] and got back and
posted up outside again
yeah
so
that [ __ ] was crazy that almost made me
sick
honestly oh they can go do some [ __ ]
come back in seconds what's up guys
they're literally posted up out outside
the [ __ ] house
so then i i don't even know like i'm
i'm trying to keep this as general
nothing that's enough right there yeah
afterwards though like
one of these kids ended up taking his
own life like two days later
whoa
yeah
and then what the [ __ ] you go do that
and then kill you like two houses down
from this spot they had a [ __ ] stash
house of [ __ ] guns and [ __ ] and like
two houses from the house we were at and
some situation happened in it like
they're having an argument or some [ __ ]
and the kid got up and just
killed himself
i have never been in an argument you
know what i don't know watch this
watch this i've never thought i've never
thought that it must be an erratic
[ __ ]
yeah don't try to stop me smee like in
hook don't you dare try to stop me
stop stopping
wow
i'm not trying to laugh at the kid i'm
just saying that's crazy
then i remember like probably two days
later we see
stan like
for some reason i i the kid that my my
boy had to explain this [ __ ] to me i
didn't understand
the kid was like
in his mind put some blame on some other
kid for the [ __ ] happening on all the
kids whose guns they were i have no
[ __ ] idea but we saw him standing
outside
waiting waiting for a kid
we were reeling up and [ __ ] and he's
like damn that's that's that's him right
there
waiting outside
i don't know what happened but my boy
made it clear to me what the [ __ ] was
going on and i'm like man i've been
chilling over here for maybe two weeks
at this point i'm like this [ __ ] this
isn't even a i mean people know this
area in buffalo but it's not what you
would fit there you'd think about if you
were just a
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] wild though
damn yeah
yeah it's actually the area i was
[ __ ] born in i'm talking about
but
yeah that that [ __ ] was [ __ ] wild
over there that that wasn't even really
a police story but no but still it's a
good it's a good uh break in this police
story [ __ ] real quick people that did
get away mm-hmm all right not us no they
used to i used to have a lot of [ __ ]
funny stretches with them because they
would just watch me
like i remember one time we were filming
a music video and they watched us like
for a long ass time i seen them watching
then they pulled me over afterwards and
i got a sick ass shot
in my rear view of the cop pulling me
over and getting out walking up to the
car and i put it in the video
see it was weird i got a [ __ ] ticket
too it was worth it where can we find
that
it's man this particular video is no
longer online and
hurts my soul
somebody went into my boy's [ __ ]
youtube account and like deleted his
[ __ ] account it's i've been looking
for this [ __ ] video for years it's
called in the hood by [ __ ] tag money
the make your own luck video all those
tag money t's like oh that it was their
video but i shot it on my little uh
remember those those cameras with the
red button
and they just had a red button and they
were like they look like a nokia man we
went all out i'm going over the bridge
in lackawanna on top of the [ __ ] car
with the [ __ ] thing well we took like
three days it was the first music video
i ever shot
but that was the one scene in it but
yeah they used to [ __ ] with us all the
time
that's east coast that's east coast cops
yeah old as soon as i moved to lac juana
i got the whole rundown about how dirty
they were warning me about this one
about that one this [ __ ] will do
this and that really yeah like some og
[ __ ] rick rush it uh-huh yeah weird
so
i don't have to deal with [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah i never had to do like i said
i i've lived here eight years i've never
been pulled over
whole time i lived there every time i
got in the car i had a [ __ ] alibi
oh god that's not fun
and you're white i got a funny i got a
quick funny one for you me and my boy
we're pulling up downtown uh at a light
right downtown by like where the sabers
play but
there was nobody there the streets were
[ __ ] empty it was late at night and
there was a cop for some reason doing
like traffic in the street but it was
unnecessary
so we kind of approached this light
and he he like hits me with one of these
and then i guess i didn't stop fast
enough slow the folk down hit me with
like an extra one so then i was like
okay [ __ ] we and we sat at the light
and let it cycle again i'm like no i'm
good you're good i was just being such a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so i sit at the light for a whole cycle
and we're just looking at this dude
and then then i take off
and then the next day i leave out of
work i'm going home down south park
in the perry projects by where rick
james is from i'm going down south park
avenue i'm bumping the game in my system
thumping the [ __ ] game
i come to like a light
this cop and i have a a pile of roach
weed in my next to me in my passenger
seat i had emptied out all my roaches on
the cd case and put it on the passenger
seat
this same cop walks in front of the car
and goes turn that [ __ ] [ __ ] down
and i was like oh [ __ ] like put my hand
over okay yeah nope my bad
same [ __ ] dude the next day
david area
no we're still downtown okay but yeah
how [ __ ] ironic is that i kept it
moving
i had a big ass pile of black weed on my
[ __ ] seat and [ __ ]
i've never rolled a roach blood or
anything so i'm very grateful
yeah i've never done that i've smoked
resin but i've never done that
[Music]
oh
all right those are fun because these
next ones aren't um that was good yeah i
wanted to bring some fun ones because i
was good the rest of them are like
they're pretty negative
save those for next time
yeah we're gonna have a dozen more what
are we at right now 50 minutes
yeah yeah we're doing a good job today
oh yeah try to keep it i like this man
we're
we're flying through it right now i like
this are you ready
let's do it
all right guys
on to story number three this is odd
this feels like story time on story
number three all right please
oh [ __ ]
oh
you're ready y'all ready for this
uh my next story
all right here we go
so
[ __ ] was
15 years old
same year but way later in the year i'm
about to be a junior
i play football i played football but i
met a lot of people through football
obviously we all go the same school so
we know each other
there's a dude named sam
he's older than me
and i didn't know he's at this party i
just bring up sam just to let you know
that he was at the party but i didn't
know yet
i'm at this random party just like i
always [ __ ] was
i'm at a random party remember i said
fence breaking [ __ ] i had a reputation
for people thinking i broke everyone's
fence
bro
there was like five people always gonna
break in fence you break another fence
so this is what happened one time
and this is where it started
you guys ready
this is where the rumors started
wow oddly enough
i'm at a [ __ ] party just getting
shit-faced
and randomly randomly dude jeebus like
one of my best friends
i hadn't really been chilling with him
like a shitload yet but i remember jebus
was so drunk and i was smoking weed and
he was like being kind of mean he's like
oh yeah that's like yo you're elena's
class why are you being kind of mean
it's the only time i've ever seen jeebus
not super nice i told the next day it
goes no i wasn't like dude you were
being kind of mean last night what was
your life no no
i just i just the only time ever jesus
looks like joey ramone
from the the ramones so uh
here we go i'm at the party i remember i
see jebus i'm smoking a blunt by like a
group of cinder blocks that everybody's
sitting on in the backyard
and i remember i'm smoking a blunt and
i'm thinking
i don't want nobody hitting this [ __ ]
blood i was smoking the blunt and i'm
with one friend it was like don't let
nobody hit it don't let nobody hit it
and then some girl walks up and of
course he lets her hit it like you're a
[ __ ]
don't let a girl hit it
she always get the thing with me guys i
don't let girls have my blunt like
random weed
that come up and just kind of hit that
like no
no because i love the look on it for a
girl's face when she goes
you won't let me like did you put in did
you even introduce yourself did you even
say hello when you walked up keep
[ __ ] moving you know what i mean if
girl was hey what's up blah blah blah
my name is this
you guys mind if i hit your joints just
one time
and i'll just give them the rest of it
goddamn etiquette yeah i have some
[ __ ] etiquette dude
and uh
yeah so usually i'll just let him have
i'll hit it a bunch of times and go hey
just keep it i am not putting my mouth
on anybody else's [ __ ] that i don't know
pre-covered post cover doesn't matter
i've always been that way
so some girl comes up she's hitting the
joint with the blonde like fear a
bitch-ass let this girl with the [ __ ]
blood damn it and we get it back
smoking the blood and i just remember
this is all that happened i'm in the
house i sold like 3
20 sacks to these dudes
i lit up a blunt in there and the owner
yelled at me so [ __ ] violently i'm
like
what you get smoking yeah
oh i just saw everybody doing drugs in a
circle so i figured it was [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] so i walked outside and that's
when i smoked the balloon outside right
i saw chibis and that girl hit our blunt
right after that girlhood are blunt i'm
standing there i'm only telling you this
because that's how short i was at this
party
i wasn't even [ __ ] drunk yet
i'm in the backyard and i hear cops and
i'm like yeah people always say that but
i see the red and blue on the sides of
the other houses oh
[ __ ] i'm in the backyard i see the blue
reflecting on tower there's always a
towel yeah i always tell look at the
walls like oh [ __ ] i've never heard
anybody else say that before yeah yeah
that's how i always make sure like some
people just talk yeah
every time i used to like it's times you
pull up and look at the side of the
houses when you're coming up a side
street and [ __ ] yep yep
so i'm in the backyard i see the light
go
[ __ ]
i rush to the side of the fence and
there's no uh gate it's just a solid
fence i'm like damn
all right and there's like seven dudes
in front of me all hop in the fence like
ah [ __ ] i'm about to put my leg up
you know i mean like damn i can't have
fences i'm short you know what i mean
especially back then so
i'm waiting for my turn for the fence
waiting for my turn waiting for my turn
and i get up and as i get up oh i
brought myself up i put my
you know like
forearm down on the top plank that's
horizontal and i start pushing myself up
i get a foot on i'm ready to get a phone
on i'm about to go over and right when i
get over my foot slips and i just do one
of these here's the fence
i just [ __ ] pull uh
benny rodriguez
i was thinking it let's go thank you
i pulled one of those feet moving in
there i was wearing converse too which
made me feel cool but he was wearing pf
flyers anyway i start flipping over go
come on dude for real
what do you think i landed in
for everyone that's on youtube go ahead
and drop a comment what do you think i
landed in
pre i mean mid blunt session what do you
think what do you think happened
give me five seconds
you ready
my whole body entire body on my back
landed in a rose bush
i broke that thing in the middle like i
ripped the rose bush in pieces because
my body went through it but i already
landed in it
and it and i was sitting there like
but i don't want to move like oh my
[ __ ]
might as well be a cactus it
it [ __ ] i had jeans on thank god
i put my hand down below me
and like
throw my shoulder over and like roll out
of it and as i do this like oh
i don't know how much got on me but it
was like on my leg but wasn't so much my
back
as i'm getting up and i'm like oh you
know when you grab your pants and go try
to pop them off
i do that one as i look up there's like
three cops right next to me all with
flashlights come on come on come on
and i'm like
oh [ __ ]
and i start
trying to run straight off the lawn the
guy's right here the fence is behind me
the house is right there
i try to run this way and the sidewalk's
right there and he looks at me he's like
yeah yeah get the [ __ ] out of here get
the [ __ ] out of he points it right at my
face i'm like oh
and then he's like come on guys party's
over come on like in uh super bad yeah
oh yeah who oh cops were here that's how
they were acting like come on
[ __ ] get out of the house yeah
i run
you guys know the fear of running down
the street
when you didn't bring the car from a
party
it's f
all right you see
anxiety came back
exactly
so basically um
this is what happened i start running
start running and i see sam sam's car
and sam's in the car so i automatically
just go and i said i didn't know sam was
at this party i run like boom open sam
door i'm like yo i'm getting in your car
excuse me close the door and i'm sitting
there and his girlfriend's right there
his girlfriend's not very nice
but she's right there she's a
cheerleader goody two-shoes kind of girl
and sam's right there and i'm like [ __ ]
this is great he has tinted windows so
i'm like oh i'm just gonna sit in here
it's like a block away from the party
right but there's a bunch of cars it's
not on no cops going to come search
every it's a [ __ ] party it's not a
big deal but to me i can't be getting
caught i have sacks on me
anyway i'm sitting in the back i
remember remember that my hair
i remember this kid mark remember i said
mark that was on the side of joe's house
and i saw him through the windows
that kid mark this bull run always on
the key was hella tall he runs up he
runs up oh open the door open door gets
in and he did what i did because he knew
with sam's car we're just sitting there
i'm like all right
all right all right let's just wait
these cops out let's wait him out
and then his girlfriend just busts out
this big sack of coke
and i had never seen anybody do coke
besides little preston's dad big preston
but not anybody like yo let's do lines i
hadn't seen coke like that yet i was
[ __ ] 15.
and
i'm thinking the first thing i think
like
you're like the dead cheerleader [ __ ]
you do cocaine but i didn't know about
drugs like that yet
i just knew people did it my mom and my
dad used to do them [ __ ] like that i've
seen drugs all the time but it was weed
for me
and everybody in the car just started
and then mark oh one let me get one of
those like you do cocaine yeah he was
like wow
and then they all just did hello rails
and i'm sitting there just
oh
oh
i got weed in my pocket i don't want to
ah i just like this is gonna get me in
more trouble than being at that [ __ ]
party
and then everybody did lines
and then uh sam started driving into
town i just hopped out and i just got my
made my way home because you know in
high school it's the biggest thing in
the world to drop a [ __ ] at the
house
you know what i'm saying now it's like
full take you home what are you doing
but in high school like you know how
much gas is
it's it's a whole different thing in
high school so
that was the party
and that's when people started oh sorry
as i hit the [ __ ] rose bush and
rolled out i look and the [ __ ] whole
fence comes down
so i forgot to mention that the whole
side fence
on the ground and i'm getting up and
running and everyone just started saying
i broke the fence
i got to school and aaron was like yeah
[ __ ] thomas breaking fences
i fell in a rose bush
i was on my back when i i was rolling
over and i saw the fence coming out what
the [ __ ]
because at another party real quick it's
not in the police at another party once
we were stuck in the backyard we
couldn't get out the fence was hella big
i remember this guy i knew and his
girlfriend his girlfriend was like
almost crying she was so scared to get
caught by the cops
and i was all [ __ ] drunk and i was
just
doing weightlifting [ __ ] i'm like don't
worry don't worry don't worry
and i punch through one of the boards
hella hard and i pulled the other one
off and right when i did everybody
started jumping the fence i was like
[ __ ] i'm bleeding
i did it because you're about to cry out
i gotta let's go cry
rip this guy's fence open real quick
and then everybody got mad at me because
i did that i was like i was trying to
help this girl thomas breaking [ __ ]
fences again
that's number two that's when
everybody's like oh you really do break
fences huh
fast forward 11th grade 11th grade
everybody calling me a fence breaker
still everyone dude all the older kids
like [ __ ] thomas breaking fences and
[ __ ] like shut up [ __ ] do you want weed
or not [ __ ] you
and uh
i would get shit-faced [ __ ] up at
these parties but i was always it was
always fun
anyway
my friends are having a party off of
gerard avenue they're all out of high
school i'm in like 10 through 11
motorcycles oh motorcycle i was like
that's the first thing i've ever first
ever heard yeah i'm in 10th or 11th
grade
all these dudes are in college i hung
out with all the older kids we talked
about it
and i uh just [ __ ] with them i'm
walking up to the house and i jump up on
the fence
what's up
just to [ __ ] with them because you know
they think it's a cop even though
they're in college or some high school
kids we're all like around the same age
like within three years and i remember
seeing bastard like
[ __ ] the fence breaking ass thomas i'm
like [ __ ] you guys as i go [ __ ] you guys
the whole board comes off bam oh [ __ ] i
smack the [ __ ] of myself right now hold
on
sorry
that's how it happened in real life
yeah it was realistic
as i'm like [ __ ] you guys the whole
fence board i'm holding
pops off and i fall with the whole fence
board i get up and look through the hole
and everybody's dying i was like man
[ __ ] you guys it's the first time
it's the first time i broke the fence
for real
[ __ ] and i just remember thinking bro
you popped yourself right in the [ __ ]
head with the board as they're calling
you a fence breaker and you break the
guy's [ __ ] fence
as they say no i'm not
sorry that's a side story
and that's the end of story number three
yeah he's called me fence breaking as
tom you know [ __ ] you guys man
i never broke the fence but joe's party
the whole fence was broken everywhere i
go the fences get broken
apparently
but also everybody else at those parties
too
so maybe they're fed breakers man
but me punching that board is what
really got people like you really are
offense break and then that [ __ ] happens
uh-huh
uh you're a fence-breaking [ __ ]
i'm a fence-breaking [ __ ] push
fences and sure yeah push wood push
trees here we go
what's up guys just want to give you a
little break in between all these crazy
stories in this episode and we want to
take this time to talk about one of our
sponsors this is liquid iv first off
huge shout out to liquid iv for being
one of our sponsors thank you so much
i've actually been personally using this
for
five plus years so let me give you a
little rundown on liquid iv let me tell
you exactly what it does you could drink
a cup of water glass water you're
hydrated with a pack of liquid iv just
one pack you're getting hydrated 2.5 to
three times faster so we're not saying
it's better than water it just makes
your water better so if you're
interested in this at all go to
www.liquidiv.com and when you buy
everything at checkout use the code yola
and that's 25 off so as i said i've been
using this for years guys honestly i'm
just going to tell you what i use it for
anytime right now it's december winter
time is when i get sick the most this
has five essential vitamins and it has
more potassium than a banana and it has
more vitamin c than eating an orange and
i'm not saying this is better than fruit
i'm just saying add it to your water and
you can get hydrated faster and easier
non-gmo gluten-free no dairy no soy this
is completely vegan it has less sugar
than an apple this is not a sports drink
this is not just full of sugar to get
you hyped up so it's christmas time guys
you're gonna be traveling you're gonna
be going to your family's house you're
going to be getting on planes make sure
to have a couple liquid ivs with you
just pop them in your water it makes no
difference to you and it makes all the
difference to your body the caramel
apple watermelon lemon lime guava
strawberry they have so many flavors
just check it out www.liquidiv.com
use code yola at checkout that's 25 off
all right guys it's been 102 this is the
first time in history marty we're gonna
hit an hour and a half
all right and after this i will never
say it again because we already
accomplished that [ __ ] okay yeah this is
the first hour and a half this [ __ ]
comes out in less than two days that's
really why it comes out one day yeah oh
yeah sorry it's it's marty's wife's
birthday today
he is was just doing a microsoft shoot
for two days so we weren't he didn't
have any time to come and and film from
[ __ ] four a.m to four a.m to [ __ ]
eight night so marty's been doing two
crazy microsoft filming days
and he couldn't we couldn't film the
podcast so saturday which is today it's
his wife's [ __ ] birthday so we're
trying to film this we can go back and
be with his wife or his birth for her
birthday because tomorrow she goes to
vegas for with her friend for her
birthday
so marty's literally trying to balance
this [ __ ] out right now that's why we're
trying to keep it an hour and a half
because within
27 hours you this has to be up on
google play
uploaded well on audio yeah tomorrow we
always by the way all the episodes on
audio you know spotify apple google play
podcast whatever you listen to podcast
it always comes out at midnight right
yeah sometimes a little before sometimes
it will after sunday night sunday night
it comes out on audio so when you're
driving to work or doing your commute
you can listen but the video always
comes out at three on monday afternoon
just so you're getting off work or maybe
you have a break you can watch it there
and uh so that's what's going on guys
that's what we're trying to keep in an
hour and a half because you this has to
be edited fully ready to go
within a day and that's
it usually has four to five days to edit
these because we go hard that's why i
thought you know what let me try to keep
this precise that's why i'm doing so
well right now usually i'm just like
just [ __ ] talking about nothing i
love this though because we got some we
got some really [ __ ] crazy guests
lined up we're not going to talk about
them
i think we're going to go on a tear of
another
bunch of guest episodes pretty soon so
it's just [ __ ] relax
yeah we got some uh there's pretty big
guests coming guys all right before i
tell you this last story we have some
really big guests coming
very excited we just said dr drew dr
drew is a big guest but we have also
have some other fools that were
we got some top we got a top three or
there was steve oh and there was like
two other people on the top of the list
and one of them is basically booked
oh
i don't even want to say it i don't even
want to say that so we're just we'll
leave it at that keep posting on that
track we'll leave it at that okay but we
have january is looking
huge you guys coming up
ah so yeah this is probably gonna be one
of the last solos for a minute i got to
be honest yeah we'll see what happens
see what happens but uh yeah that's why
i wanted to say that's why it's gonna be
an hour and a half today because we
this has to be [ __ ] edited in a day
and it's her birthday today so basically
it's edited tomorrow and thank you guys
for showing so much love in that rosy
episode and just letting her feel that
love that was amazing she's so
comfortable now she's fine
after we left and we got like oh that
was fine like as soon as i realized like
oh we're just hanging out yeah yeah so i
never wanted to force her to do it
or like come on come on it'd be good
come on
but now whenever you're ready to come
come on
did great yeah it's the biggest episode
yet yeah the terms of a week
the most views we've ever had in a week
which is crazy tight yeah then i got
interest out he got age restricted and
just it just view stopped
but it's all good and did it did great
and she's comfortable way more
comfortable now so that's the biggest
part so she can come back we'll do a
full episode we even talk about a bunch
of [ __ ] yeah oh my god barely talked
about anything we haven't talked about
stuff that her and i have done together
it was just stuff before me and her got
together yeah
the [ __ ] that me and her have done is a
whole other episode
um
so yeah there we go guys
and last note we should have the the new
collection out for christmas too oh yes
it should be
rolling out around the week of christmas
we have three shirts coming out sticker
packs coming out the shirts are [ __ ]
awesome
all right
yeah excited i'm excited local it's
going to be so much better we're going
to be able to like do so much more we're
going to be able to test out [ __ ] and go
pick up a couple and send a [ __ ] out to
the fans and you're going to be able to
buy it right on dopaziola.com yeah
podcast.com which is going to be
connected yeah to dope as usual which is
not which is the app yeah sorry this
shirt so tired of my arm sorry
do the shuffle over here yeah
the merch is coming very soon i'm very
excited it's gonna be sick where do we
at want to wait
all right got 15 to 20 minutes to tell
the story i want to yo i'm i'm proud
right now let's do an hour and a half
all right here we go
this last story
yeah you said you haven't heard it so
we haven't talked about it on here
here we go guys this is all from season
one so you would have never edited any
of these videos anyway all of these ones
i got
i like this this is good this is cool
here we go
last story all right this is the story
time episode this is the police
encounters
doesn't get any better than this ready
go
i
am 21 21 years old i have my weed card
everything i'm still selling weed
doing my thing working at me and ed's
though the pizza place and you know
jeebus my friend jeebus i got him a job
there and deuce i got him a job there so
we all work at the same
spot oh you know what this is one of the
times when john my dealer just
disappeared
because now i remember now like why
would i have more wheat because i didn't
have any weed i hadn't re-up yet this is
the time where i was buying weed to
smoke
in between waiting for packs
the first time i ever did i hated it
so that's why i didn't have a bunch of
weed this time so i wasn't really
selling i was selling weebles at my
house
it's not like i had a bunch of sacks out
i was going to my friend leo and
michael's leo and michael from dos palos
they moved into this house which michael
owns and then my little brother ended up
moving into like 10 years later which is
weird
so
i am on
i can't remember the street i came in
the street but it's brought off oleander
and before parsons so if you're from
merced you know that area oleander
parsons area
so
i'm just parking my car i got a sack of
sour something i can't remember this
fireweed and ryan sold it to me and it
was in this big medicine tube you
remember before you used to carry around
like jars it was in the twist off
medicine bottles maybe you guys still
have them the orange ones with the white
lid [ __ ] yeah yeah but i had the [ __ ]
fire nugs one quarter filled up those
jars
and uh
i was going to michael's for a party
and
we park there's no there's no parking so
he lives in a cul-de-sac so i park on
the main road which is connected the
cul-de-sac just like normal
all right as i'm getting out of the car
as i'm getting out of the car
i see a cop at the end of the street
rolling up i'm like who cares totally
cool be chill out my trunk because all
my weeds in there
and asthma as i open the trunk i'm like
oh he's getting closer close the trunk
i'm like don't take your weed out yet
no no sorry sorry it was deuces weed
that was in the uh
trunk i believe
i had weed in my trunk i put it in my
pocket yep i put it in my pocket i had a
letterman jacket on this really nice
letterman jacket i liked
i put the weed in my pocket the medicine
bottle and as
as this [ __ ] is rolling up he
shines his [ __ ] spotlight from his
car at us
i'm like what the [ __ ] as he's starting
to get out i just like
because look at guys there's only a
split second you can hide something when
the cops around all right i'm not trying
to give you advice
to be a criminal but
when he's getting out of his car
they're not always looking straight at
you as they get out of the car there's a
split second where they look down at the
ground
put their foot down and look right back
up that's the time that's the only time
you have when a [ __ ] is getting
out to talk to you
so it's dark um i heard i had put black
tape around my wee jars because keeping
the sun out of your weed is good because
it the sun [ __ ] your weed up just being
in a jar leave it on your shelf the
sun's not good for trichomes anyway i
put black around my jar i remember i
kept that that medicine bottle the
orange one but i put black like
electrical tape
and i just went
just dumped it as soon as he got as soon
as he started getting i went i put to my
pocket
but not like
hey
i did the underneath my waist like
dump it you know hey throw something
real small like
i try to dump it without my body moving
so he like would you just throw huh
so i did it and he didn't see it [ __ ]
bomb
so officer nelson you [ __ ] this full
starts searching us even though it's
illegal we didn't do anything all we got
all we do is get out of a car
all we do is get out of a car he starts
searching us he finds deuces weed he
finds jesus sweet that's right they had
their weed on him i was in the trunk so
when i got it out of there
i ditched it started searching us and
cuffed us
we didn't do anything all right that's
not [ __ ] legal what he did
so we're all sitting on the oh no we're
standing right there on the grass where
the grass meets the sidewalk because we
just parked in the street
and he starts saying i'm searching guys
blah blah blah i'm like what the [ __ ] he
finds deuces jesus weed so automatically
they were getting charged with
possession and this is back
when weed wasn't like oh it's just weed
it was still like oh you do you want to
go to jail it was still like that you
know
we all had our cards so it wasn't a big
deal but merced didn't really give a
[ __ ] about cards at that time oh prop
215 yeah not here merced county is a
[ __ ]
so he's like yo um so like search your
car blah blah blah blah i'm like no no
i don't know what this eagle scout did i
don't know how he knew
i don't know what the [ __ ] he he didn't
see me throw anything
he's talking to us and just goes
what's that
i mean it's pitch black
he has his flashlight look at us just
goes uh
there's
there it is jeebus
deuce me
flashlight just goes from conversation
to what's that
points right at the [ __ ] medicine jar
i don't know how
in the world he saw it
he walks over there
picks it up it's closer to me because
i'm standing over there
and he goes huh whose is this huh
i go
it's just trash in the street man
and he goes so i'm gonna charge you for
it since it's closer to you go that's
not my weed
and in my head i went
you [ __ ] idiot how do you know it's a
weed
you [ __ ] dummy
and i knew right there i'm like oh i
[ __ ] up but did he catch it like in
men's society oh you know you [ __ ] up
right
you know you [ __ ] up right first
that's how i did it in my head like oh
but in my face in reality i went
that's not mine how are you gonna
discharge me it's a [ __ ] drug drug
area what the [ __ ]
and he uh goes well you're closest to it
so
you're getting charged with it i'm like
that's not [ __ ] right blah blah blah
he opens and goes whoo
i'm like in my head like yeah
but he goes
closes it back up and he goes hydro
shut the [ __ ] up hydro you're just
saying
words at this point shut up
trying to actually you know what weed is
[ __ ] you
oh hydro puts it in his pocket right
so uh i'm gonna search your car i go no
you can't search my car he goes bro do
you want to go to jail tonight do you
want to leave with a possession charge
i'm searching your [ __ ] car
and i'm a dumb kid i didn't realize
that's [ __ ] illegal
he opens my car starts going through
he's like i smell the more we like i
smell the weed bro i smell the [ __ ]
weed and i had more weed in my trunk
all right i had more weed in my trunk
and i just didn't want him to find it
so
he's searching my car and he's like i
smell it man i go dude i have roaches
everybody's like
that's roaches
you're going to tell me that's roaches
i don't know he's like bro that's fresh
sweet i know the difference between
wheat and smoked weed and my head i'm
like [ __ ] me too
[ __ ] of course it's not the same smell
[ __ ] and i was just trying to see if he
was dumb and he's like oh so do you want
to make this harder you want me to
search your whole [ __ ] car he's
starting to be kind of a dick and the
other car cop that rolled up was playing
nice guy oh what's up guys like i know
the marijuana laws are you know barrel
it's our job
yeah cool
and the guy searching he goes so i'm pop
pop the trunk blah blah blah i'm like
go ahead man do whatever you're gonna do
he goes like that with a key pops it
goes by law i'm not allowed to search
your truck whatsoever without a warrant
unless you tell me it's okay so thanks
as i as he pops it uh by from the state
law i'm not allowed to open your trunk
unless you state that i can so thank you
for that
and pops it
and he pops it and goes under the
[ __ ] tire all right it's right there
and he opens down like he says all right
there it is i mean it reeked
and i'm like all right it's right there
[ __ ] man come on jesus christ and he
found like a little bit more weed
and he put that in his pocket
and it was not much weed but he put that
into his pocket
took the jar the bottle out and started
writing the evidence thing on but put my
other weed in his pocket
right but didn't start writing that when
he wrote the evidence [ __ ] down right
so now we're all sitting cross-legged on
the curb i have the letterman jacket on
like i said
and now you start coop being cool to us
he goes hey you know where you're [ __ ]
up huh and i go i know
i know how would i know what the wheat
and i'm like how would i know what's in
the [ __ ] jar goes exactly bro that's
why i'm charging you and i know i just
didn't think you caught it man i
remember having a conversation like that
at this point because we're all getting
charged at this point i'm like i just
i didn't think he caught it all right i
know i [ __ ] up that was a dumbest [ __ ]
i could see is the dumbest [ __ ] you
could have said so at this point we're
like
all right you're not so bad we're like
[ __ ] with each other all right all
right you got me [ __ ] and you go so i'm
be real nice you have way more weed and
you lied to me
do you want to take all the charges
i was like yeah i'll take them all and i
don't even look at my peripheral and i
know jesus induces like
oh
thank god
i might you just
yeah i'll take all of them because
what's the difference
i got charged with the most
throw throw all the weed in there it's
fine i took the charge
and he's like you're not going to jail
or anything like oh [ __ ] yeah ball he's
like yeah dude just gotta go to court
don't go oh [ __ ]
this sucks
so i'm sending indian style and goes all
right get up i'll uncuff you
i'm like no can i just stand up by
myself man cause i don't want you to
pull me because
i just got this jacket i don't want i
mean i'm heavy i might rip can i just
stand up by myself and deuce goes he
just got that jacket man
and he goes oh yeah for sure he grabs me
by this and just [ __ ] yanks my ass up
anyway rips this underneath oh god brand
new jacket rip sis what the [ __ ] brand
new expensive ass jacket i just bought
and uh i heard you go
just get me the [ __ ] out of here what am
i gonna do what's what's really gonna
happen and i know they heard it too and
then like
oh my god you just ripped this
motherfucker's jacket
so what's the worst part of this all
right ready hold on
he starts saying all this stuff he goes
hey man i'm gonna clock out he tells the
nice cop nelson [ __ ] that did all this
to us
tells a nice cop hey man just i'm gonna
take off from here bob you got the rest
of this
kept the weed
[ __ ] kept the weed in his pocket
what i'm surprised he ain't keep all of
it he smoked the weed
you bastard so not done i walk into the
park after all this is done i'm just
like my check
i walk into the party and everybody's
like yeah what's up we're like
for real and we explained to him
everything like yeah right we would have
heard you guys
you got it what outside yeah for the
fast fast 30 minutes we've been out
there
yeah right we all i pull out my ticket
like
what's that address say what time is
that
are you [ __ ] kidding me worst part of
the night i had no weed for the night i
was heated
story's not over what time are we at 120
120 oh perfect this joints out
do the rest of this with no joint
so
a little bit of backstory here
still work at the pizza place i'm a very
good employee i've come to know some of
these customers because i delivered to
them all the time some you know oddly
enough some people order the same thing
every week it's very cool
like i don't know it was cool like i get
the same thing every [ __ ] point blah
blah blah don't you forget my this i
know you like four rangers [ __ ]
i know what you order but the fact that
people ordered the same thing always
tripped me out anyway there's this
really cool dude
next to the school his name was rob very
nice guy he orders the [ __ ] pizza
certain amount of ranches every [ __ ]
time right
same dude all the time
i mean same order same morning he's
always really nice to me you want to be
here man i'm like no thank you but i
appreciate it and in my head i'm driving
[ __ ]
weirdo
you want a beer driver no but i
appreciate it i also look 14. you even
ask me how old i was
rob very nice dude orders the same [ __ ]
the reason i'm bringing this up as
you'll find out in a minute
i get that case i find out where my
court case is and i go to court never
have i ever been to court and i remember
that guys i have
12 packs in my house
when i got caught with a little [ __ ]
ass amount because i [ __ ] finally got
a new connect that [ __ ] dirty dan
[ __ ]
stinky ass dan as my was my new connect
because john disappeared
and um
so this is what happened guys i go to
court and there's a bunch of delinquent
criminal [ __ ] in this thing i
don't know if you're into court but you
have to sit in the pews and they call
your name and then you go up you talk to
the judge do your [ __ ] you [ __ ] leave
so everyone has to hear what you did
everyone has to hear everything your
name your [ __ ] your cork
[ __ ] man
so all these fools are going up looking
for
theft and crazy or [ __ ] like why am i
here
right
so
before i get into the courtroom standing
outside waiting in the line with
everybody right
i walk in
i see a familiar face
i walk in and who's the bailiff at the
door that lets you into the courtroom
rob
that orders every friday the same pizza
we have a conversation every friday
because we're always like hey what's up
man tom's
hi rob see you next friday that kind of
relationship nice and i see him like
what's up rob in my an outer one like
hey rob hey how you doing man
and then inside i go
[ __ ]
[ __ ] are you gonna be in there
[ __ ]
and he's like
you're coming to court
yeah yeah i have a little just a ticket
he goes oh okay okay yeah i'll see you
in there
oh [ __ ]
get in line we go in and rob's the
bailiff guy that holds the paper
and lets people the judge know who's
coming up next
he's the guy
in all the courtroom cases
let me get you a smart ass comment yeah
with a smart comment
he's that guy except in real life
i'm going in there and rob i'm sitting
there and every time like you see me
like a
buddy thing
rob's 50 years old 45 years old i'm a
[ __ ] 20 year old you know like he's
just like the kid from the pizza blood
thomas i like that guy
robs
i didn't know what to do
i don't know what to do
i they call my name
and i like here
and people start laughing at me like yo
get up i'll come up to the front like
got you i'm a rajo with an a
you know i'm saying there's only like
one or two people in front of me and
some of them were on the monitor
thing like you i i don't know how the
court works
but i hadn't seen anybody walk all the
way up and do this [ __ ] so i'm like
here
and all these delinquents start laughing
at me and [ __ ] and then the judge like
come up to the front sir
oh
oh and i walk down the middle and
everybody's like snickering at me like
you guys are all [ __ ] delinquent
[ __ ] criminals i don't know
where to go sorry [ __ ] i've been doing
good my whole life not getting caught
not getting caught you [ __ ] scrubs
[Laughter]
i walk up there and there's rob right
there he's like yeah
i don't want to look at rob because i
know what's about to happen
look at the judge the judge is an 80
year old man
he's an old ass man with white hair
like if james woods the actor was 85
that's what he looked like
not mean
not nice don't know how to call it
doesn't look i don't know how to call it
different
yeah i'm just
oh what's this guy going to do to me
you know i mean like ah man
okay i'm in trouble because i had a car
and i still got in trouble
and um
the judge starts reading off my [ __ ]
charge and i don't want to look at rob
because i know rob is like
what did you get charged with
where is my tip money going every friday
i got caught on a friday
i had just delivered to rob hours before
took his tip money and bought away from
ryan
yeah so he bought my weed that i'm
getting charged for at his job
i can understand him right he's a
[ __ ] not a drug smoker so
he i she's like possession of blah blah
blah blah on the corner of this black
ball was saying all my [ __ ] what officer
blah blah and i just like peek over and
his whole face is just
not rob he's just like i'm a bailiff and
i don't like you what a [ __ ] ass
his whole attitude just dude that offers
you a beer every time thank you
thank you
you guys ready for this my favorite
[ __ ] part of the story all right
this man is going over my court cap my
thing is like hey so
marijuana smoker huh
yeah sir i just i was caught like you
know sorry
it wasn't a lot but he goes
marijuana
you guys ready
quoting all right ready i'm the judge
down there is me there's [ __ ] rob and
all those criminals behind me the
camera's you
i'm the judge's
marijuana charge huh pot smoker
oh yeah sir i did the whole thing it's
not a lot he goes
marijuana
is that approved by the fda
and i go
huh
and he says is marijuana approved by the
fda
old man like [ __ ] up christopher lloyd
looking old man like just look at old
man white hair
and i say
i don't
think it is
because the fda the federal drug
association or administration like no
it's not considered a legal drug by the
fda i wouldn't be here he goes and i go
i don't think it is sir and he goes
then it's not a drug is it
and it took me three seconds and i went
oh
you're tight and he goes not a drug
right why would i charge you for drug
possession then
and i look at me
i don't know sir
he goes
why are people wasting my time he looks
at he looks at robbie thank you why are
you wasting my time with this
because some marijuana charge this kid
and he looked at me and i go i don't
know he goes uh this is now a
misdemeanor pay 100 fine
just go about your day
the old man just looked at me and goes
get out of here that man's a burglar let
me talk to him and he goes hundred
dollar fine misdemeanor be expunged oh
thank you so much sir you're like go to
the front pay your [ __ ] fine you talk
to blah blah blah
next
i left and as i'm getting my style i
look at rob and rob's doing this one
he's like looking off not like when your
dog's mad at you
he's not even looking at me when i leave
and i went oh okay paper passer never
never ordered again
what a [ __ ] ass never ordered me and
ed's again
and i'm the delivery driver on i i know
when he's gonna wonder what day i'm the
same guy every
never did rob order again for me and
adds ever ever ever again
paid my hundred dollar fine
and that was it
what a cool old man
that's what amazing that just warmed my
soul dude the way he said he's like
i'm i like you it's fine i didn't know i
didn't get that he's like
i'm letting you off uh-huh i didn't get
it because i'm like i was sitting there
i thought it was [ __ ]
fda i don't [ __ ] know
am i going to jail i didn't know what
was happening he's like i'm going to
drop this to a misdemeanor
in front oh no i'm going to drop this to
an infraction sorry he called it an
infraction
it was a pay hundred dollar fine it was
116
i was pissed that i had paid for what
it's either right or wrong [ __ ] why do
i owe you money thank you
i had to for possession so yeah it's
meaning to pay 116
and um
that was it man
what a cool judge man what a waiter is
it that is not a drug
then it's not a journalist he's probably
said that [ __ ] ten thousand times oh for
sure he had him feels good and then he's
like give me my hundred bucks and he had
it unlocked though he's like
like that was the thing he always says
yeah yeah yeah but i remember just
thinking
all these fools are snickering behind me
i just got let off [ __ ] you guys i'm
gonna go smoke weed have fun in [ __ ]
jail
what's the time 1 30. 1 30. yeah let's
go
that's the end of the story i feel like
we could do like three or four more of
these
oh police story time oh i have
i scratched barely scratched this could
be a three-hour episode barely scratched
it real quick before we end
we said we wanted to talk about what
happened to our friend
just because it's the police encounters
i'll be very vague because i don't want
to put a [ __ ] out there but it's also
[ __ ] crazy crazy my friend uh you've
made in many videos i'm not going to say
basically whoever you don't see a lot
late from now on this is who i'm talking
about
[Music]
how else do i put it bro
my friends going to jail right one of my
homies was going to jail my good friends
he was supposed to be going to prison he
got a very good lawyer
they worked some [ __ ] out and this
[ __ ] is only going to jail they
said you can hang in the holding center
for some time right right
my friend they only gave me a year which
is great out of what they were gonna
give him which is crazy they gave him a
[ __ ] year
the judge told him a couple months ago
so you can turn yourself in any friday
at five o'clock between now and the end
of 2021. so basically he said hey you
know friday at five when everybody's
having fun come to [ __ ] jail
you have to turn yourself in my friend's
been sitting here like
all right what week what week
what week should i go like dude just go
before christmas you're gonna buy
nobody's [ __ ] you miss the holidays you
come back fresh
because you won't do a whole year you
know you'll do less
so like just miss all day save some
money on presents [ __ ] get out
of here
so we chilled like the night before he's
leaving all this [ __ ] blah blah blah
we're like two days ago it's two days
ago we're hanging out last night the
night he goes to jail
i'm talking to him a couple hours before
like yo hit me up before you go uh blah
blah blah here's all my information
write me when you get in there i'll put
money on your [ __ ]
jail [ __ ] right
his mom's driving a minute she's all
emotional and [ __ ]
and i'm like oh man 6 30. this fool's
gone he's i'll call you right before 6
30 if i have time
it's 6 34 i'm like
he didn't call [ __ ]
all right i'll see you so i'll see you
on the [ __ ] screen soon [ __ ]
like whenever call me write me ready
let's ready to go i gave his i got his
mom's number we exchanged all of our
information and [ __ ]
and uh
my dance fall's in jail
i get a call
at two in the morning from who
from very same friend
this is a [ __ ] i go why aren't you
in jail
why aren't you in jail
and he's like oh also also
he bought before he bought some clothes
off my friend tyler and he did he never
sent him the paypal website i'll
continue when i see you
and my friend he's going to jail he's
not going to pay that little bastard
my friend leaves
the night before we hang out he leaves
and leaves his weed there and my friend
that he owes money's there he goes
i'm keeping his [ __ ] weed
you should you should keep his weed
because he owes you money now you're
[ __ ] even on the night he leaves one
of the odds
anyway he calls me two in the morning oh
why aren't you in [ __ ] jail
he goes
listen he gets into the [ __ ] jail
does the processing gets dressed does
all his [ __ ] and the guard goes you're
on my list for next month get the [ __ ]
out of here
my friends never turned himself in had
to willingly turn himself in goes to
jail is ready to go to jail they told
him not today get out of jail
come back later come back later
he goes go talk to your judge because
i'm not letting you come in here until i
see you from the judge like as if he
really is like he really wants to do it
yeah like a bouncer exactly
exactly like wait
but he's he turned himself in
and you're telling them do you know how
strong you have to be to turn yourself
in every time i think about
i just think of uh goodfellas he sees
everybody pops pills
now take me to jail and then bam now
he's in prison that's what i always
think of
and um
he hits me up and goes
hey man i left my weed at your house can
i come pick that [ __ ] up i just need to
smoke weed i go
sorry little mishap
everybody's gone
[Music]
i took care of your debt already
yeah don't worry
that's clean
but you're also weedless damn
so did he feel amazing or did he feel
he's pissed he's pissed like bro i'm
mentally prepared to do a year [ __ ] i
already moved out of my apartment oh
he moved out of everything he [ __ ]
everything's in stores
everything he's gone he's like i'm just
gonna move out i'm gonna be gone for a
year
and now they're like come back next
month
next month so but he's trying to get
he's like i'm trying to go to jail
tomorrow and i'm like yo did you hear
what you said oh i'm trying to go to
jail tomorrow this is the most stressful
thing i've ever heard in my life he's
trying to get in he's trying to get in
the club so he can start a sentence
i told you i knew i did they made them
go every weekend for a year that's great
oh i would love to do weekend jail [ __ ]
oh bro just know you just know your
[ __ ] weekends are busy great cool i
want to be here every day
[ __ ] bomb
i don't i think i would love it drive me
crazy i would love it yeah i mean i
guess it's better than being there when
he's in there he tells me they did the
same thing to the guy next to him and
the guy only had to do one night
so the guy sat through all the
processing just to come back the next
day oh [ __ ]
that sucks
so uh just real quick i just want us
through that throw that on the police
account because we were talking about it
before we started filming because like
guess who called me he goes who like
were you astonished i was editing sashay
saw his name pop up yeah
what the [ __ ] why aren't you in jail
it was really funny honestly
how are you calling did you sneak your f
yeah what was your thought did he sneak
a phone in no my first thought was like
you're not there
what happened because i told him i feel
like with your charges because it is a
serious charge like but the only the
time you got
covet
overpopulation
the county you're in i feel like they're
gonna make you go hey just go
you're fine because they're turning
non-violent offenders right out
overturning get out get out get out
they're cutting their sentences by 90
and i was like yo i feel like you're
just gonna call me the next day like yo
they let me out and i thought like no
wait
why aren't you in jail and i was hoping
i was gonna hear no way that's what i
was hoping but he's like i heard was
just disgruntled
friends cursed
[ __ ] up got no weed got no cows no
weed got no house and i still gotta go
to jail
[ __ ] we gotta sit around the next month
thinking about the [ __ ]
oh
you'll be fine
it'll be fun it just sucks it just sucks
yeah
uh let's hope they find some new [ __ ]
evidence
over this next month or some [ __ ] his
whole court case is completely over
[ __ ] no it's [ __ ] he got the
reasoning on trouble was [ __ ] illegal
he still got charged
that's just the way it is
he needs to hire [ __ ] freeway rick
ross to figure this [ __ ] out in the next
month
just take the year and move on with your
life
it could have been
nine
so just take it let's take it
um police encounters all right and if
you're in jail because you did get
booked watching this friend
don't worry you'll be good i'll i'll put
some some soups on your books
real soon and some juices
for real for real that [ __ ] sucks man
actually goes a long way in there yeah
it really does um i'm just trying to
stay positive because it sucks dude it's
like [ __ ] man you're in jail this is
this
this sucks
[ __ ]
i know i just actually
all the time this time being said that i
thought you were joking like oh yeah i'd
say [ __ ] with your friends so much all
the time this motherfucker's going to
jail tomorrow that would have been like
a normal thing to say i don't like to
say that out loud though because
i don't like [ __ ] to come true yeah
that's one thing i don't [ __ ] with yeah
oh this fool's dead i'll let you say
those two of course but like oh this
full now he just [ __ ] he lost all his
money in two seconds saying he's [ __ ] i
say stupid [ __ ] all the time when i
answer the phone who are you with just
all this guy he's
like found him on the street like you
say stupid [ __ ] but i remember
go to jail tomorrow
you're like
like no for real he's going to jail
tomorrow
yeah we're all just taking dabs and [ __ ]
so he goes to jail hides by a horrible
[ __ ] thing we told to eat a shitload
of mushrooms and then go in oh no
you might have an epiphany and be like
yo this ain't [ __ ]
or have a mental breakdown
jesus christ i wouldn't do it guys by
the way we don't got to get into it but
i mean april trip [ __ ] balls
oh oh we're gonna do it next yeah just
so you guys know i'll try to keep it we
talked about last episode this is a
child's play already finally lost
his brain and tripped i still gotta
recount it but we'll leave you on a
cliffhanger for that one what are we at
136 yeah you did a great job yeah did a
great job let's go all right all right
this has to be edited in one
[ __ ] day dude this was uh
not seeing any sunlight or anything
really [ __ ] me up because i don't know
what time it is right now what time is
it
3 20. oh that's not bad
we doing good all right guys thank you
so much for being here
this is uh episode eight of season two
the next couple weeks are going to be
guest
filled
we'll see all right we'll see we'll see
i don't know when the
train of hell the guests are starting
but
when you're juggling all the like
celebrity schedules man
we'll see though i'm amazed that we get
anybody every [ __ ] everybody's so
busy yeah
yeah but
guys thank you so much for being here we
have a lot more coming a lot more stuff
this one was straight up story story
time episode
police encounters
thank you guys so much for being here
thank you for watching thank you for
supporting if you're in the car please
be safe marty go get that [ __ ]
app and it's only listen the app is
one percent of it's just the infancy of
where we're gonna take it but it's gonna
be it's gonna be the main it's gonna be
bigger to us than youtube it's gonna be
bigger
that is the [ __ ] to be
in tune with as far as dope as yellow
goes because it can't be [ __ ] with yep
and we're changing the name we're
changing the look we're changing a lot
of features
this app is like you said it's in its
infancy
it's gonna be completely different all
right
but in a positive sick ass way
this is gonna be bigger than anything
we've ever done it's so cool being able
to like you said earlier you remember
you you know this fan's username uh now
we get to look at all like connected
yeah shout out to humanity yeah yeah
yeah i've just seen humanity in the
comments on the podcast and he would say
yeah you check out my shroom sometimes
like whenever i can blah blah you made
an app on the account and i just showed
you a [ __ ]
crazy great intro shrooms we i try to
post on there every morning early
morning every morning i get up i post on
the [ __ ] app
yeah i i just
we're the way we're gonna make it more
functional like functionality wise it's
gonna be way easier so you'll be able to
post more like instagram keep your
pictures have your profile that's the
next question that's the next thing yeah
so um
yeah dopezola app in the app store and
in google play store we're changing the
name so when we do change the name we
will show you and tell you guys and
blast it out there so you know just
because thomas wants it to be bigger
than just to have it be just about
thomas yeah i don't want that yeah i
don't know
we want it to be a real community we
want it to be a hub for everything
dopeziola and so you guys get to push
notifications whenever we drop something
and have it be just like the website but
also
what makes it really different from the
website is that we want people to have
their own profiles and their own
community and i want to highlight people
doing sick [ __ ] yeah
like instagram should you know they post
celebrities and they should be posting
content creators
we're going to be [ __ ] with the
contractor i'm not saying we won't put
celebrity
but the content creates you're the odds
now you get to pick thank you we're the
oz now like we're verifying [ __ ]
we're verifying people that deserve a
[ __ ] verification
you know what i'm saying i'm so ironic
am i saying the rock's not going to come
like oh give you a check mark for the
rock
talk about [ __ ] super sick ass
photographers out there that should have
that [ __ ] check mark that don't
because maybe they [ __ ] with weed
not here you can come get your
verification you can make your [ __ ]
[ __ ] look sick this is gonna be that's
why we're changing the name i don't want
it to be all it's dope is the old app i
want it to be an app that you come and
go oh yeah by the way marty and [ __ ]
thomas made this [ __ ] app up
i want it to be another social media
logo that you click when you wake up
that's what i should say yeah that's the
way it's going to be and where it's
going
so thank you guys uh we have i don't
know how 45k 45 000 members in one week
and like almost over like 1500 five-star
reviews on the app bro amazing we never
even thought to even bring that up i
didn't even think about that you guys
are five-star rated app when you type in
d-o we are the first thing that pops up
in the [ __ ]
app store yeah
that's big that's huge
huge
and
and all we did was we wanted it for push
notifications and now it's turning into
another social media app that we're
going to [ __ ] run with so thank you
guys for being here download the app
anything else marty
you got your your drop coming right
pretty soon for the dopest oh the dopest
uh yeah dopestop.com dopis drops 1217
shippable to all 50 states
not illegal
it's all 50 states
the new apparel oh yeah we have a
bachelor's degree
yeah should both be out for christmas
then right mm-hmm
hell yeah
we're we're leaning on the clothes
dropped the 17th he says if we can get
it done yeah yeah and so does the dopest
app yep i mean the dope is shot people
are getting leaned on so you guys can
have this [ __ ] for christmas oh yeah
and the clothes are gonna be sick we'll
post some mock-ups and teasers soon but
uh i can't wait to post it
i know we do it's so sweet yeah
um anything else
that's it thank you guys
[ __ ] is crazy right now [ __ ] is awesome
i feel like we could do 10 hours today
oh for sure yeah really i feel like yeah
this is the shortest episode i feel like
i have the most energy just to keep on
going yeah but it's okay guys
thank you for for watching i went
through every episode last night to find
out the stories like i said watching the
progression
watching
it's [ __ ] weird man your first camera
angle was behind your head
from the sidewalk down you're framing
you've never really talked yeah
second episode you talked a little bit
and then by like i was like episode 10
that we're having full conversations i
never planned on being a co-host i know
but it worked out so much better dude
that whole plan was mario just to run
the [ __ ] and like chime in producer yeah
here if you need me
yeah and it turned into a whole [ __ ]
two-man operation
hosting this [ __ ] so
it's better so thank you guys so much
for just watching it and watching the
progression we're in season [ __ ] two
we're coming up you know i mean almost
like a year in a couple months we're on
like eight months ten month eight nine
yeah so thank you guys so much for being
here thank you for everything that's all
i really wanted to say thank you for
supporting thank you for watching uh
dope as usual
uh podcast clips adobe digital podcast
clips channel go watch that
the numbers are getting [ __ ] good
yeah we're dropping clips on [ __ ]
they're great there's a lot of clips so
thank you guys so much for watching the
clips
and i think that's about it man so thank
you guys so much for watching uh this
has been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast marty o'neal over here my
name is thomas dopeziolo whatever you
want to call me
um yeah man that's it so if you're
driving like i said be safe before you
leave here on youtube drop a
[ __ ] like if you can drop a
comment notification bell
just remember no matter what
notification bell or not every monday at
three o'clock there is a new episode on
this channel no matter [ __ ] what
every monday at three o'clock so thank
you guys for being here and for everyone
in the chat thank you for staying
until next time guys i'm dopaziola have
a dope as day
i should have rolled more weed
i'm over here let's go staring at this
roach
i shouldn't roll more weed
remember when we did the ads first and
now we're done
i feel like a straight adult too
not [ __ ] up yeah
[Music]
perfect
[Music]